welcome back a TV host gets banned for
being a mean little man
but when this failing late night host is
rude he will apologize always for food
yes it's time for
Don blue it you get it he blew it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
former celebrity
James Corden has reportedly apologized
for his rude behavior that got him
banned from a fancy New York City French
restaurant called Balthazar never been
there it's my reception was anyway it's
unclear if he actually felt bad about
how he acted or just missed doing shots
of their garlic butter
[Laughter]
of course he won't apologize to staffers
at Planet Fitness until Hell Freezes
Over
that's funny about balthazar's owner
Keith McCown McNally announced the ban
on Instagram yesterday calling Corden a
tiny [ __ ] of a man
and the most abusive customer in the
restaurant's 25-year history
but the owner's credibility was in doubt
after he called Gordon a hugely gifted
comedian
that only makes sense a subtle fat joke
according allegedly had several
raids-filled meltdowns at the restaurant
over stuff like wrong orders and a piece
of hair in a dish which although
annoying are far less upsetting than
having to sit through more than 30
seconds of his car karaoke show
which AAA calls the number one cause of
people smashing their cars into walls
hours later though the owner changed his
mind explaining that since Gordon
apologized he deserves a second chance
especially with the amount of food
according to orders Balthazar can add
Dental to the employee benefits package
Jim
you're you seem like a nice person but
I've never really been out with you I
don't know you could just be an animal
when you don't get your gazpacho right
yes have you ever been banned from any
restaurants for uh Behavior or bad just
from anything well Greg you're being shy
um I first of all obviously we should
not be smirch uh unhappy cruel little
late night talk show host
um wow
but I I remember you remember forget we
went out one time and Greg uh is not
easy
um it was the eighth anniversary of our
friendship every year go out and uh we
eat in a French restaurant we laugh and
uh you ordered bacon and eggs and I
remember you said I want my bacon so
crispy I can snap it they'll hear it in
Kentucky we laughed for 10 minutes it
was great good line it was funny
um I think they laughed a little too
hard uh but then they brought you limp
soggy bacon oh no I believe it tapped
into something because he was like it's
not my fault I'm tired
um and then he slapped me in the mouth
with his bacon yes I did yep I did I
heard you your story I hurt you yeah but
I still ate it I know I know but then we
discovered that we shared a certain
fondness for some kind of activity yes
we both realized that our bacon is not
working properly either I'll go right
back to that folks
that's easy
[Laughter]
surprised by this man's behavior so I'm
a big proponent on treating people with
respect I believe we're all made out of
the same fabric with that said I love
James and I am one of those viewers that
watches karaoke I think maybe because
secretly I think maybe subconsciously I
can't think to save my life but in
another life I think I was a singer so
maybe I'm like pitching myself to be on
his karaoke show well you can pitch
yourself right out of here
very nice I'm joking that was a joke
America you hurt my feelings oh I'm
sorry I'm not really sorry but I am
sorry you know
ordered an omelette for his wife did you
see this of course I did what did you
I've been reading about this all day
it's an all yoke omelette I had to
Google it yes never heard of such a
thing I know yeah it looks gross it does
look gross why would you do that I don't
know but I guess he just these aren't
even like the worst thing people you
know when someone says oh this guy was a
jerk at this restaurant the worst part
is not being banned from this restaurant
it's now everybody's giving all these
stories oh I saw him being one time too
and some of them are really bad yeah
some of them are bad like the one on the
plane what do you do that like so there
was like he was on a plane and then a
woman came out with a crying baby and
they're like he's gonna be a jerk but he
just sat there he put like his eye mask
on noise canceling headphones until the
end of the flight the woman was up
getting the luggage out she said could
you at least hold the baby it was his
wife and his baby no
guy that sounds too great I don't I
don't know if it's true or not but
it doesn't have to be someone said on
the inner well I mean look if you get
that pissed over a little white and your
yolk omelette which most people don't
even know exists how do you think you
treat your baby yeah exactly I think he
should have his kids taken away we
should call Child Services because
they'll end up at my house
I'm at my limit
Baker's dozens my limbs like I don't
care how much the cute and look like me
um
he's uh he's he's going through a tough
time for unemployed late night hosts uh
because the woke aren't used to this
because you can't you know I remember
um Bill Maher I think he has a show on
TV I can't remember he had he put some
pictures up about how America looked on
you and you were that you came out too
and you talked about how obesity is the
thing and he shamed everyone like how
dare you how dare you and he's used to
being able to walk into a place and say
elitist things like I'll have an all
yoke omelet so that means the poor
bastard in the back has to check crack
eggs dump all the stuff out and then
pour the yolk there is no way that there
will not be any membrane connected to
the Oak impossible but just something
elitist will say just and then there's
one little thing what did he ask for I
want my drinks free too so yes you're a
jerk you never asked for if the if the I
get a lot of free stuff when I go out to
eat and stuff you know why I'm a good
Tipper and I'm respectful and I tip so I
can come back
this guy is used to being the walkway
where the fear of calling him out on his
BS will end up with a Twitter protest of
his restaurant right because that's how
it's been for the last two years now
they're looking around I told you that
little Old English lady who told us
about the slave ships those two thousand
English guys that died on CNN she
started another Revolution because now
the Walker getting called on and they
don't like it he banned him looked
around
and no one said nothing yeah so that's
changed hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else